hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm standing on my stationary bike
in the middle of my apartment which is a
horrible mess because it's always a mess
here at markiplier HQ so forgive me for
that
because I'm having a million pounds of
trouble trying to upload videos to
YouTube right now which is really
aggravating because I can get to the
rest of the Internet just fine but I'm
unable to do it for my videos so I
apologize for not having content today
so I decided to record this village
my phone to answer a question a question
that has been plaguing me for some time
and that has been asked for a long time
now because I've been getting a lot more
popularity right now and I'm so grateful
to you guys for doing that I still can't
even believe how many subscribers were
getting a day it's unreal and I owe
everything to you guys but this question
has been hunting me for a while and it
is how do you become more successful on
YouTube it's a pretty simple question
and it's asked a lot I'll admit but my
answer is actually just as simple the
way to get more successful on YouTube or
in anything is simply to believe in
yourself and you may be going out now
that's that's a cliche and it's of
itself but actually hear me out on this
one it's a it's a simple answer with a
complicated explanation because when you
start anything not just YouTube but when
you start anything you're alone most of
the time nine times out of 10 you're not
going to have anyone that wants to
support you you're not going to have
people that believe in you you're not
going to have people that want you to
succeed because there have been people
that have done that and have failed
and because they have failed they think
that no one else should be able to
succeed and this applies specifically to
YouTube but also generally to life but
in YouTube it's even harder because if
you think about it there are thousands
upon thousands of people that want to do
exactly what you want to do especially
when it comes to gaming I mean it's
different for different genres but for
gaming there are a thousand people that
can pick up a computer play games record
themselves in do commentary and that's
really intimidating for a lot of people
it's really intimidating and it was for
me but then again when I started YouTube
and a lot of you
my story but when I started YouTube I
didn't go into it trying to become this
amazing commentator in fact for the most
part when I started doing YouTube I
wanted to do Let's Plays because it gave
me a chance to practice my voice which I
wanted to do to go into voice acting
which I'm probably need to try to start
into pretty soon I have done a few
animations here and there but I'm
getting sidetracked now when you're
starting YouTube because other people
have done it in have failed and because
no one has your back that's the time
when you need to trust in yourself more
than anything else because when I
started I had nothing but time I had a
whole lot of time and no one to believe
in what I was doing so I had to believe
in myself and I had to push myself every
day to get up and start working on
YouTube and you know what it was easy
for me because I knew what I was doing
and I was doing it for entertainment
purposes I was doing it because I loved
to do it I love to get up you know and
take a new challenge try something new
do something better than I had done
before and improve on myself every day
but the only reason I was able to do
that and get up and spring out of bed
and stay up late at night lose sleep
over it was because I believed in myself
you know I believed that I could do it
from the first time I started to get
popularity I started to get subscribers
when I hit that first first thousand any
of this before I lost my first channel I
you don't know I lost my first in you
know my adsense account got banned and I
had I just start all over again but this
even before that when I got that first
thousand I realized that I was onto
something good and it was part in
partial to my dedication to what I
wanted to do see I dedicated 12 hours
out of my day every day and a lot of
people don't have that kind of time but
that like unwavering dedication and
unwavering belief in yourself and even
though I got tons of criticism you know
outrageous amounts of criticism that
kinda is you know I'm still getting some
of it today but I've learned to ignore
it you know just people that want to
bring you down people in the comment
section saying you're stupid you're ugly
or no one likes you or no one wants to
watch you they're watching you right now
but then you get other people that start
to notice what you're doing and that's
when it starts to become easier
you still believe to believe in yourself
even as you get much more popular but
thanks to you guys I have had the
benefit of being able to you know take a
vacation because you guys have my back
so much and that first year of work was
just me grinding my bones to dust trying
to get this to work but it was all worth
it and it all worked because I believed
in myself and that belief in myself
caught fire in you guys and then you
guys started believing me and then who
knows tomorrow who will believe in me
and if you start something and this just
doesn't apply to YouTube this this is
not just about YouTube this is about
anything you do this is about school
this is about work is about starting
your own business this is about being
your own person you have to believe in
yourself because that fire and that
passion I read this analogy somewhere
where you have this burning passion to
do something and it doesn't matter what
it is so long as you believe in it and
that burning passion will start to catch
fire and the fire grows bigger and
bigger until other people around you
start to notice that that guys on fire
they want to find out what it's about no
need to be like oh he's going to burn
himself to the ground or they're like
holy crap he's on to something and you
see this small belief this one belief
one person believing in yourself is all
it takes to start snowballing down to
this incredible plateau of something
that you can create out of nothing and
I'm so proud tab you guys am i back to
be able to do this and do charity
livestreams and be able to help the
world in ways I never thought possible
you know we've raised over $70,000 I
don't even know because I wasn't even
able to keep track last time we did a
charity live scene but we're well over
70 70 thousand dollars in terms of
charities and that's a passion of mine
that has caught fire and you guys and
I'm so proud that you guys believe in me
so if you have the question in your mind
how do you become successful at anything
anything at all you have to start by
believing in yourself and that's a
question that I wanted to answer for
quite some time
now as far as everything else I will try
to get the YouTube videos to upload as
fast as I can
there's been some power outages here and
there I don't know if like there's a
server down or something like that all I
know is that this apparently works so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart I
am I I thank you guys for everything
that you've done and believing in me and
my cause and I want you guys to take
home if any lesson from this stupid
video is that whatever you do be it
small big have a goal and believe in
yourself so thank you all so much for
watching there are no annotations don't
even bother clicking in I don't even
know if there will be a description on
this sumbitch but thank you guys so much
for watching you are the reason I do
this and the reason that I am still to
this day so excited to be able to make
videos for you guys and I am so
disappointed in myself for not being
able to get them to you so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye